there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
sixteen rules for living with less a
free ebook which you can download right
now at the minimalists com slash
resources enjoy and minimalists hello
simpletons I was having this thought the
other day Josh tell me when you paint a
house on the outside uh-huh it gets
bigger but if you paint a room on the
inside the room gets smaller
Zeno's paradox hello everyone I'm Joshua
fields Wilbur and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalist today
we're gonna talk about minimalist
fashion we're gonna talk about capsule
wardrobes we're gonna talk about
cleaning out your closet we're gonna
talk about the pros and cons of trendy
clothing with today's guests Courtney
Carver is back in the studio and Janie
she has a new book out it's called
project 333 which I'll hold up for our
YouTube audience if you're watching this
on YouTube now before we dive in
according to you know our show is not an
interview show we don't interview people
we we answer questions and so we have
some questions here from our audience
today but before we get to those it's a
left been 11 years since you launched
project 333 wild I think so it's almost
10 okay 2010 2010 right 2010 2020 yeah
if you're including the year 2010 and by
the end of 2020 okay I think this is a
mass podcast I've been really know if
it's math I have to go okay fair enough
and so project 333 but for those four
the six people who are uninformed can
you explain what that is and let's talk
about why the book now sure so project
333 is as you guys know a minimalist
fashion challenge where for three months
you dress with 33 items or less
including clothing accessories jewelry
and shoes I'm sorry I know like a lot of
people stopped listening when I said
she's right but shoes count but here's
what doesn't count underwear doesn't
count so if you want to have 33 pairs of
underwear be my guest
lounge wear sleepwear and workout
clothes don't count but your workout
clothes must work out if you don't want
to count them we're still underwear Ryan
can you believe this not true minimalist
if you ask me here's the thing I I don't
think I mean I think I probably fit
within the the 33 items and you do it
for three months that so you don't like
throw out all your clothes right I
recommend you not get rid of anything
that's right after the three months and
so in a weird way it's sort of like
Ryan's packing party but for your just
your wardrobe and you just you store the
stuff away you have your 33 items and
then over the course of three months
you're wearing just those items but they
tend to be your favorite clothes right
they do and what's so interesting is
that so many people who think I could
never get down to 33 items are already
wearing only 33 items but they're still
sorting through all their other crap
right yeah they're trying on the
oversize blue polka dot thing that's
going on and their closet by the way I
am wearing polka dots and something and
so they're wearing this to whatever is
going on in their closet they'll try it
on and it doesn't work or they'll wear
it throughout the day this used to be me
at least where I would put on the thing
and I'm like I didn't enjoy wearing it
but because it was my clothes that I
felt compelled to wear it's got a nice
brand name so I'm gonna hold on to it
right a little pony logo but what's this
what's the statistic we only wear like
20 percent of what's in our closet 80
percent of the time I don't know where
that came from but yeah that's fair yeah
it does I mean it's it's interesting I
know I totally would have fallen into
that back in my corporate days when I
had all the suits and the Allen Edmonds
shoes and the ties and the different
color shirts yeah it's crazy though
because that that 20% of the other
wardrobe we wear a hundred percent of
our wardrobe takes up out our mental
space all of our attention all of our
resources I mean when I think about how
much money time energy and emotion I've
put into my wardrobe over the years I
think
could I have done that to something that
I couldn't really care less about I mean
even when I thought I loved shopping and
clothes I still didn't really care about
it so why did I divert all of that
energy towards this monster I posit
right and also all this energy that is
actually making me discontented in a way
now the funny thing is right when we go
out on tour right we're actually getting
ready to go on another tour right now
the less coast tour and as we go out on
tour it seems to me always the
best-dressed people are people who are
currently participating in project 333
I'm pretty sure I shared that in the
book because when you said that to me
one time I thought oh my gosh he's so
right like people really do look and
feel better about themselves even though
that wasn't the intended goal of the
challenge it is one added benefit for
sure now one snap from the book now
let's talk real quickly about the book
here it says the average woman owns five
hundred and fifty dollars in clothing
that has never been worn and you know
when I was going through my mom's stuff
down in Florida when she passed away
over a decade ago I I found she had 14
winter coats in her closet and she lived
in st. Pete Beach and some of those
coats still had tags on them in fact
many of the clothes in her closet still
had tags on it and why do we do that
it's a really common thing I can't be in
a room with people and ask that question
do you have clothes with tags still on
and not have more than half the room
raise their hands I mean we I think are
conditioned to go after that great deal
and we get so excited about it that we
forget whether or not it's something we
even want in our lives but we just want
to score that deal at least that's what
how it worked for me and then I'd put it
in my closet and I would never come
around to wearing it and I'd never cut
the tags until I wore it so there it
would be with the tags still hanging on
it reminding me what an idiot I am
for spending that money yeah you've got
a lot of people you've helped a lot of
people with project 333 why the book now
why was now inappropriate
to put this in a book form so my first
book soulful simplicity had a chapter in
it called simple as the new black and it
was all about project 333 and like
almost every conversation I have it
became kind of the star of the show like
whenever I talked about I could talk for
an hour about anything and mention
project 333 for five minutes and that's
all anyone wants to talk about
afterwards so it made sense that there
would be a book really helping people
figure out not just how to do the
challenge but to help them with their
objections to the challenge and excuses
and also find other ways to do it to
break the rules to make it really work
well in their lives yeah I think it's
nice about the book too is because you
can talk about project three through
three all you want until your face turns
blue but when other people talk about it
and their experiences with it and you
share some stories in the book it really
helps other people connect with it a lot
better I think we've got some questions
here today Rachel in Baltimore is first
up I struggle with being a minimalist or
attempting to be a minimalist I call
myself I want to be minimalist and just
the thought of enjoying keeping up with
fashion so I think those two things
sound very separate and probably binary
kind of black and white but I do believe
that fashion kind of makes our first
impression on people and yet I have the
mentality that I don't want to spend a
ton of money on clothing and keeping up
with the Joneses in that aspect
so Courtney rachel has I think this is
one of the most common sort of things
that comes up like I want to become a
minimalist she says she's a want to be
minimalist or or she just wants to
simplify her wardrobe but at the same
time feels this alternate tug of well in
order to make a good first impression on
people I need to be fashionable what
would you say to someone like Rachel so
much to unpack here a lot of people feel
this way and they either want to keep up
with fashion or they love shopping and
the second part you want to make a good
first impression which assumes that
people even notice what you're wearing
and it's been my experience that people
don't notice what you're wearing and
that was really a blow to my ego at
first because I used to dress to impress
I used to dress for a certain situation
it's a phrase dressed to impress
Wow yeah I never even put the two
together yeah and I did a lot of like
okay if I am going to be meeting a
client today I have to wear a suit and
awesome high heels so that they know I'm
super powerful and I can close the deal
yeah when I started dressing with 33
items or less I was working full-time
selling advertising ironically and
nobody noticed that I stopped wearing
all the things and that I was only
wearing this small handful of clothing
in fact for a full year I was still with
that company while I was doing the
challenge and no one said a word about
it and I worked with the kind of people
who would notice or who sorry would say
if they noticed but they never did and
so that gave me so much freedom and
knowing that first of all that's not how
people aren't really judging you and for
the small select people who are who
cares if you impress them or not like if
that's what they're gonna focus on
you're not gonna have that deep
connection or meaningful connection that
you're looking for anyway because
they're too consumed with their own
feelings about their own clothes because
when they're judging you they're really
not thinking about you they're thinking
about themselves like that's how we
that's how judgment works right we say
something but we're really just talking
about ourselves and our fears and so
don't worry about dress to impress or
prove yourself wrong or right by doing
the challenge and seeing if you impress
fewer people over the course of the 90
days yeah I totally agree like Rachael
needs to get behind the why like why
does she care about being trendy if it
is about you know other people's
judgments on her it's like do you really
want to go out of your way to impress
people who are going to judge you based
on what you wear I'll tell you what
though retail companies and clothing
companies love when people get this
insecurity because this causes them to
buy more goods like I mean Rachel if she
is in a professional setting as you need
some professional
we're closed but does it have to be the
latest trendiest thing I mean is that
gonna yeah that might even get in the
way in a weird way when something is
yeah I have a few sort of minimal
Maxim's here that maybe we can unpack
together first one as trendy is just a
fancy way to say soon to be out of
fashion hmm I mean when you think about
things that are that are sort of
timeless when I say timeless something
within our lifetime timeless I don't
mean that like the are three outfits
were wearing right now we would have
been thought of as insane people when
the 12th century in England or something
wearing this but now if I walked in with
like a suit and a boulder hat on you
would be like what are you doing hipster
yeah but actually you know we're gonna
talk about this maybe during the Maxima
but I've got some really good examples
of people who have timeless wardrobes
that would work today the same they
worked in the 50s or the 90s or whenever
in between and so my second minimal
maximum here which we can put in the
show notes as well is trendy looks good
today timeless looks great every day and
I think that too often when we when we
chase a trend what what happens is you
look at the people who were sort of on
the cutting edge of trendy say in the
90s I'm trying to think of like NSYNC
for example the band see hammer
MC Hammer is a great example Fenella is
another great example right and so you
have these these trendy folks who were
really at the moment in that exact
moment were sort of the epitome of cool
and fashionable but imagine if someone
was even if Courtney wood walked in here
today we're in the MC Hammer pants or
the vanilla eye itself that you would
have been like what are you doing yeah
and so trendy is is is chasing something
whereas as wearing something timeless is
a way for us to still be ourselves and
express ourselves but not in a way that
is well we talked about this last week
with with Pete Peter Allen's mimetic
desires versus personal desires trendy
is a mimetic desire it is imposed on you
the society as a whole and if you can if
you can let go of that I think what you
do is you actually bring your real self
to the forefront yeah you may notice you
don't really feel that comfortable in
the trendy clothes either because it
doesn't really fit you like your
lifestyle or your personality so we try
to fit ourselves in a not I'm not using
that term like fit your body but try to
fit into these these ways that were
supposed to look and then we end up
feeling like phonies if Ryan came in
here today wearing a fedora it probably
wouldn't work because he that's not who
he is right there are some people we
have we have good friends like Andy
Davis I've never seen him without a
fedora yeah and he totally pulls it off
it looks great on him by the way he's
gonna be performing at our Sacramento
Show come on yeah I cannot wait anyway
Rachel I'm gonna send you a copy of
project 333 because I'd like you to try
it out for three months you don't have
to get rid of any of your existing
clothes just set them aside put them in
some boxes and and make room for your
favorite clothes I bet you'll feel
better at the end of those three months
our next question is from Chloe in well
our old stomping grounds Troy Ohio which
is a suburb actually it's where podcast
Shawn grew up he grew up just just south
of Troy and tip City and so we have a
question from Chloe in Troy Ohio I've
recently pared down on my belongings
including my wardrobe I now love
everything I own and only what I only
kept the items that are most versatile
and look the best on me in my opinion
however no matter how confident I feel
leading the house it seems that when I
see other women who look trendy and
fashionable I start to feel my
confidence dissipating I'm not sure why
this happens and was wondering if you
guys tend to feel this way too or if you
have any suggestions to keep me from
giving in to the temptation of expanding
my wardrobe just to look trendy and when
I feel this way Coria I've certainly
noticed this with me and with other
people where we simplify but then we
still feel the tug of of the tantalizing
consumerism
and so we see other people and of course
the best recipe for discontent is to
compare ourselves to the lives of other
people it's why Instagram is really good
at making us feel bad about ourselves
you could tweet that shot so corny when
when I don't know if you ever struggle
with this or if you work with people who
have struggled with this but quite often
we we feel good about ourselves until we
see someone else and then all of a
sudden we feel like we have to do what
they are doing yeah interestingly with
this challenge I found myself becoming
more confident because I wasn't relying
on my outsides to exude that confidence
and show the world how put together I
was when the reality was I wasn't all
that put together so I felt again like
we were talking about earlier just kind
of fake so really starting to become
more me dressing for myself and and just
being myself even though that wasn't
probably measuring up to a lot of
people's standards in terms of being put
together I felt better and more
confident but I can understand when you
see someone else especially in the very
beginning that you think maybe I should
be doing that too and that is the the
comparison trap and that's all it is is
a trap like there's no winning no
getting out until you decide I'm not
gonna focus on that I'm not going to
compare myself to other people it's a
huge mindset shift but it really is the
only way to break that kind of that oh I
need that because those shoes are so
cute that she has on or she looks so
darling and her blazer
I need that because you know that when
you wear that blazer you're gonna look
different like it's not gonna look the
same on you as it does on her or on a
mannequin or whatever yeah well I think
Chloe really what she wants is she wants
to you know stand out in her own
individualized way and she's looking at
someone who who is standing out and
she's like oh I want to stand out like
that but there are ways to do that with
a capsule wardrobe I mean I you know
wear black all the time and I wear
orange shoelaces because it's like one
little thing I can like pop off and like
not just have this whole Gothic look
going on but to your point to Courtney
like when I talk to people my
personality is the colour like that is
that is the the trendiness or that is
the accent that is Who I am and people
they might look first at me which I
would argue with this wonderful smile
they don't think this but maybe they
look at me at first then they're like
and they're like man that guy he looks
like God he looks gothic he wearing all
black but as soon as I start to talk to
me they realize that like I am far from
that
so yes Chloe please don't pressure
yourself to look like so and so who has
the awesome blazer wear shoulder pads
are women still do and shoulder pads
these days I have no idea but like don't
don't compare yourself to others just be
yourself and your personality will speak
for itself but again if you do want to
do a little you know be a little trendy
and kind of stand out a little bit pick
something like your shoe I mean I think
there's something small you can do
that'll help you stand out and still
look you know a little trendy you know
my my wife deals with the her and I were
talking about this just a couple weeks
ago she's like I always I see someone
who's who in fact she just wrote about
this on her blog minimal wellness but
she she was like you know I see someone
who is really trendy and all of a sudden
I feel compelled to dress like that
other person but of course whenever I
think Bex almost always looks best like
she never looks better than when she's
wearing like a white t-shirt and like
some faded blue jeans like like there's
something elegant about simplicity I
think with with minimalism the bones are
the beauty of the thing now Courtney you
talked about this in the book though it
doesn't mean that everyone has to go out
and and dress and all monochrome either
right yeah it's really interesting there
are so many colorful patterned capsule
wardrobes out there and often times look
the first thing usually I hear from
people when I show my wardrobe is oh
it's so boring like so much black so
many neutral colors but here's the thing
my life is really interesting and before
when my wardrobe was every color every
pattern everything I had to give so much
attention to it because of course only
one thing matched with one thing
that I think it took away creativity
from other areas of my life and made
other areas of my life boring and so to
switch that with such a great trade I
mean now everything I wear goes with
everything I own that's kind of labor
Garanimals
know you don't do what are they
Garanimals Garanimals no maybe I don't
remember how to spell it you make it
sound like the tony the tiger animals
but it was this little system for kids
forever ago where they were like they
had little pictures of animals to tell
what matched with what i'm almost sure
it was called Garanimals okay anyway
anyway so yes you can wear whatever you
want within these 33 items it can be
colorful blacks not the answer for
everyone but for me even when I had all
the things I was still wearing mostly
black like the items that were because I
was just more comfortable in them yeah I
love what you said about you know how
you have an interesting life or maybe an
exciting life it's like do you want to
have an exciting life or an exciting
wardrobe like you don't have to have
both yeah
and I think part of that has to do
really with with priorities here and
it's not that you want to not make your
wardrobe a priority at all it just seems
that maybe sometimes we put too much
emphasis on the Wardrobe and as though
if I buy this shirt or this blouse or
this pair of jeans then I'm going to
feel more complete Andy Davis has that
great line we were speaking about Andy
Davis a moment ago he said we struggle
to pay rent because jeans are expensive
yeah and that is really just
highlighting mismatched priorities right
and so Chloe I also want you to get
really clear on what your priorities are
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection with
12 different chapters about 12 areas of
intentional living one of those chapters
is about getting your priorities
straight I think you'll find a lot of
value in that so if you like our podcast
you're like the audiobook version of
that or if you want the book book or the
eBook version we're happy to send those
to you as well all right Ryan what time
is you know what time it is it is time
for us to answer your text messages yes
indeed you can text
questions and comments - 937 - Oh two
four six five four those text messages
go straight to Ryan's and my phone and
we answer our favorite questions on the
podcast or we'll also respond to you
directly the text message now we can't
answer every single question but we do
reply to a lot of them cut in there
yesterday I was like instantly
overwhelmed I was like I'm not gonna do
this right now I'll hop in there for
like half an hour or so and I would just
respond to a bunch of people as many
people as I can now during the lightning
round this is where Ryan and I and
Courtney today we answer questions with
just a short shareable less than 140
character response and we put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media and you
can find all of our minimal Maxim's in
one place over at minimal Maxim's com
now Courtney don't worry you don't have
to actually make it a hundred forty
characters we just ramble on a bit until
we get something good oh by the way this
text message thing again the number nine
three seven two oh two four six five
four we're getting ready to be we're
gonna be in Salt Lake City next week
strangely money so we're gonna I think
we're gonna do we used to do these like
little small events called tweet ups
remember tweet ups back in the day where
we'd send out a tweet and then a dozen
or five dozen people would show up at a
coffee shop I think we're gonna do that
with the text message group now so if
you text us and we'll be able to send
out a text just to people who are in the
Salt Lake City area and as we go to more
cities I'd love to try this this model
out and have a few dozen people to show
up at a coffee shop so the only way that
you'll be able to know and maybe we can
drag Courtney out to this so this Victor
she lives in Salt Lake City well we'll
let you know about it and yeah lots of
fresher haha anyway we got a question
here Ryan yeah Erica America how do you
ensure your clothes last longer I wear
the same clothes that I love but they
need to be replaced quicker especially
shoes so that was the thing about the
challenge right about a project 333 is
like you lose people at the shoes right
and and so Erica is asking how do I make
my clothes last longer and here's one my
minimal maximum is I'm recycling our
most
popular one here love people use things
because she said I wear the same clothes
that I love and and and I want to
discourage you from loving your clothes
and I want you to enjoy your clothes I
want you to use your clothes I want you
to feel good about the clothes that
you're wearing when we love the clothes
I think sometimes what happens and we
need more words for love anyway right if
she doesn't mean that she like
heartthrobs over her clothes and her
clothes burn up she would have a funeral
for them and cry it's it's it's just the
word that we kind of throw out there and
not really thinking about the problem is
with the language we use also has a
weight to it right and so I I try to
save that that we're in fact that we've
got Ella saying you know I don't love my
toys I love mom and so like trying to
use the more appropriate language so
saying I enjoy my clothes or I use my
clothes that's one way to maybe untether
from from that feeling you have but
Courtney she she says yeah I want
quality clothes but I feel like I always
have to replace my clothes what do you
say I say do laundry better yes so
people ask me about laundry a lot like
I'm really surprised I think my next
book is going to be all about laundry
because it always comes up within the
context of the challenge and I'm
supposed to fold myself well you have
socks so I don't do any more or less
laundry than I did pre project 333
however I do laundry better so I wash
all my clothes in cold water and I line
dry almost everything so that's what I
recommend I think it'll really help in
terms of your clothes lasting longer
just don't put them through the dryer
and and if you do put them in the dryer
use like a wool dryer ball yeah those
are oh yeah they're great and fabric
softeners so bad for your everything
shouldn't be in your house
so yeah with detergents like yeah wrong
detergents they have all the chemicals
they'll destroy your clothes there are
some great affordable eco-friendly
detergents I don't know the names of any
and now a word from our sponsor just
kidding
so yes that's how to make your clothes
last longer and otherwise think about it
like this when your clothes didn't wear
out you had all it's because you had so
many backups so it's not like replacing
something is worse than owning twelve
versions of it right right I mean that
that's the thing I'd rather have one
high-quality pair of pants than ten
crappy pairs of pants that I mean that
does me that's worse for the environment
it's also worse for my psyche and for my
closet and for my home and everything
else right and so having the appropriate
amount doesn't mean you're gonna have to
never replace you're not gonna buy 33
out of their clothing and say well I'm
set for life no I'm set for a season now
it doesn't mean a literal season but
whatever that season of your life is but
occasion you got to replace some things
I have my shoes resoled from time to
time but eventually I have to have those
replaced even and it's okay it's not
about consuming nothing it's about
consuming less because you're consuming
more intentionally yeah and when you're
wearing like the same like my jeans for
example they will wear out within and
well if before I was started getting
Mission workshop which this is not
sponsored by nishin workshop they just
have really good high-quality jeans but
before that I was wearing my jeans out
probably once every 6 or 7 months I
never want I never walked I never wash
them well you know it's funny Josh him
and I will like purchase the same exact
like phone or you know like our laptops
that we got however many years ago like
we get it at the same time and my stuff
will always break and wear out first
josh has very kindly lovingly pointed
out to me I'm very rough on my things
because I you know I'm not um yeah I
don't care about how they look or you
animal yeah yeah I'm very enthusiastic
with my things but what I'll say though
is in might this leads into my pet the
answer which is err on this err on the
side of quality not trendy so when I go
to purchase clothing I am looking for a
high quality product and like for
example my t-shirts again not a spot
but they're from son of a tailor and
they do really awesome work like you
they literally give you shirt that fits
you great you send them measurements
they'll send you a couple shirts you try
them on if it looks good you order some
more and they're a little bit more
expensive per t-shirt but like I've had
these t-shirts for like going on three
years now and like they have I mean
they're starting to fade a little bit
but but three years old whereas before I
would get like an American Apparel
because it was it did look good on me an
American Apparel like at some point was
like you know cool and trendy but they
would wear out really really cool
American Apparel shirt right now and
that's that's actually a really
important thing to highlight wouldn't
you say Courtney like what works for
Ryan may not work for me may not work
for you and vice versa right and so it's
not about what's appropriate for someone
else and then applying that to our life
it's figuring out what's appropriate for
you
right yeah there's no you can't say this
is the rule and it works for everyone I
wish I could you just have to figure it
out but by playing around and and and
just seeing it would be so much easier
if that was the case isn't it I don't
know why the lake here are the seven
brands I can't live without and you
shouldn't even well you know it's
interesting is I was have this
conversation yesterday with Jillian and
Nathanael from the bergamont a great
great band by the way if our listeners
haven't heard of them check them out but
we I was talking about how we human
beings obsess over the one like we are
so fascinated with the best the greatest
I mean to the point where like most
religions are monotheistic these days
it's like we are so obsessed with the
perfect one because it's so much easier
if we could just be told what the one is
but you know what if you want to find
the one for yourself like it takes a
little bit of work yeah yeah and I think
that mentality of the only shirt you'll
ever need or the only whatever that
you'll ever buy that it it's appealing
because it it seems simple but it's
actually simplistic and there is a
difference between the two when we
oversimplify something that requires a
bit more nuance what it actually creates
is a form of spartan ism that is also
not healthy I mean hoarding is one side
Spartan ISM is the other side of that
same the same
all right before we get into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week yes we do
Ryan what is the best place to shop for
minimalist clothing we we've got several
places we can talk about who are the
most stylish minimalists you know we'll
talk about some stylish people I'm
looking at one he's looking at Cortney
right now how do I let go of the regret
I feel for getting rid of previous
clothing items that seems to be a big
one this one came up a lot right also
how do I create a minimalist fashion
brand that bucks consumerism we might
argue about that what are your best tips
for online shopping and what to avoid
how can you keep a very small wardrobe
from feeling boring how do you
incorporate bright colors and patterns
without looking like you're wearing the
same thing repeatedly and what are the
five best and five worst clothing
companies in terms of sustainability
Plus we're gonna talk about capsule
wardrobes and much much much more
several more questions for Cortney
Carver and if you want to hear all that
listen to this week's maximal episode
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different much longer much more personal
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the space
we need to talk about things we don't
usually talk about in public also it's
the best way for us to fund this podcast
keep it 100% advertisement free when you
subscribe the minimalist private podcast
on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app find all the details at the
minimalists comm slash support Ryan what
else here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi this is
Nancy from Iowa my 91 year old mother
who lives in a senior apartment complex
stayed at my home for Christmas we
watched some DVDs that my middle lust
millennial children watched years ago
these Disney movies musicals and teen
comedies were things that she had never
seen before she laughed a lot and it got
me thinking that most seniors in her
complex had not seen these light-hearted
comedies and musicals either we boxed up
all of the movies my children loved but
now stream instead
and donated them to the senior complex
for their weekly movie nights these
movies are now also seen in the
neighboring nursing home hi my name is
Chi made possible
I just wanted to recommend a book called
simplicity parenting by Kim Jong Paine
and Lisa and Roth and it talks about
similar things about how to parent
simplistically and I also wanted to
recommend Waldorf education wal gorf
founded by Rudolf Steiner this kind of
education I'm a Waldorf teacher and it
really just aligns with a lot of the
principles that you talked about and I
think it's a really great source really
good choice for education if people want
to live aligning with minimalist ideas
alright so thanks again to Cortney
Carver for joining us today a few things
check out her book project 333 also her
her daughter Bailey have a new podcast
together you got to check this out it's
called soul and wit we'll put a link to
that in the show notes and you can find
her blog as well the thing that inspired
us very early on when we first embarked
on minimalism it's called be more with
less they'll also be a link to that and
the show notes and real quick four right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
actually two things Ryan at the end of
last year or the actually beginning of
this year a lot of people make
resolutions right I want to read more
I'm gonna read 52 books this year a book
a week and sometimes these things become
so like outlandish we just give up
really quickly right but I know a lot of
people do want to read more and read
more books specifically and so I wrote
this essay called why did we stop
reading and I'm gonna put a link to that
in the show notes as well but in there
it also talks about the four my four
favorite recent books that I read over
the course of the last year so I you and
I are very fortunate we get to read
quite a few books just for the podcast
in fact but I read quite a few books
last year and the four that really stood
out to me
in that essay so I sort of talk about
them and why they really resonated with
me you can find out that at the
minimalists comm slash reading and also
Ryan we're getting ready to go on tour
yes we should talk about this right now
okay let's announce the tour guests so
that we're going to have so we're doing
eight tour stops mm-hmm and help me out
with my math here if we're doing we're
gonna have two guests at each style
Graham a musical guest a special musical
guest and then we're gonna have a
special podcast guest yes
I'd eat stop so if we have two guests
over eight stops I believe that sixteen
guests if my maths is right he's got a
calculator out for this one so you are
correct and we're gonna have 16 guests
we're gonna talk about each of those
let's just sort of start from the south
and work our way up in San Diego I'm
doing this from memory our special
musical guest is going to be Railly
Nicole who we love her music she's
actually opened up an event for us in
San Diego before and so we're gonna have
her back is she is wonderful and and
it's like the perfect San Diego vibe
sort of music - so she's gonna open the
show with that and then our friend leo
bob alta who has never been on this
podcast before eventually yeah he is he
just moved to San Diego he was in our
documentary he's certainly one of the
people who inspired us early on to
embrace and embark on this minimalist
journey on this minimalist journey but
he is going to be our special guest in
San Diego and that is going to be what a
great song yeah he's so insightful and
you know full of those in wisdom yeah
and hopefully that'll rub off on us and
he'll be answering your questions with
us on stage moving up north we're gonna
be in Orange County
Erwin McManus who has been on this
podcast with us before one of my
favorite episodes that we've done he'll
be the guests there and our musical
guest in Orange County is going to be
Rosie Golan who's also been on our
podcast before yeah that's gonna be a
fun event and then in Los Angeles who's
gonna do our music in Los Angeles I
don't know Lee DeWyze
oh yeah that's right you booked Lee - I
know
[Laughter]
it all starts running together Noli is
yeah he's one of my favorite artists man
it's such a great live show he's been on
our podcast before yes he has and he has
such you I've seen him live before him
what an amazing live show so you can
open up with a few songs and then we're
gonna have Eric Weinstein as our podcast
guest in Los Angeles oh we keep going
north in San Francisco oh this is gonna
be good so the podcast guest and the
musical guests are actually the same
guess in San Francisco one of my maybe
my favorite podcast episode of all time
that we've done is one we did with Matt
Nathanson yeah so he's not only going to
be our podcast guest but he's gonna play
some of his hits at the at the opening
of the podcast in in San Francisco wait
a minute if he's doing both at my maths
were wrong no I still got it's 16 slots
he's filling the filling oh okay and
then we're gonna move well I was gonna
say North but it's really more East to
Sacramento and Sacramento we're going to
have as our podcast guest TK Coleman
yeah and then Andy Davis is going to be
the musical guest
yeah then so we all love TK he's been on
this podcast more than anyone and he's
gonna be at our Sacramento stop so you
can come out and join us there and then
moving north Portland so actually our
last three stops have the same musical
guest and I'm excited about that because
it's one of our favorite people Canyon
City so Paul from Kenya City he's he's
opened up for us several times in the
past has one of my favorite albums of
all time called satellites and he'll be
at those last three stops in Portland
and Seattle and Vancouver actually those
are the first three stops last three on
my list here so he'll be there and then
Kevin Rose will be our podcast guest in
in Portland and then in Seattle Noah
Gunderson is going to be our podcast
guest yeah we've never talked to him
never met him one of our favorite
musicians but he has a heck of a story I
can't wait to talk to him about that
and then finally in Vancouver to be
announced I'm still working I'm waiting
on one final approval before I can
announce this so if you're in Vancouver
and
and you're looking forward to it so my
and I can't wait to announce it so
coming very soon if you're on our email
list you'll know about it but those are
the 16 slots that we're filling so it's
not just the Josh and Ryan show with
podcast Shawn and Jordan and Jess in the
background we're gonna have some amazing
people with these stops you're gonna
answer your questions we're going to
talk about minimalism we're gonna talk
about philosophy we're gonna talk about
a lot of stuff and you can find all the
details that the minimalists com a slash
tour get your tickets well you still can
hope to see you there oh and by the way
we talked about doing the Salt Lake City
tweet up but with text messages yeah
we're gonna do that in more cities if
this one works out well in Salt Lake
City so you can text us nine three seven
two oh two four six five four is the
number that goes to both Ryan Ryan's on
my phone we try to respond to as many
people as we can even though we can't
respond to everyone all right you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for this podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
com comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our e-mail list at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week for added
value this week this one is for podcast
Sean it's certainly one of the people
that was a big influence on him for a
long time it's it's amazing that how
were touched by people that we we never
meet right we don't get the opportunity
to meet and so Sean is a drummer and and
he was very much influenced by Neil
Peart
from Rush and so I thought we would
listen today to honor
Neil who who died recently we're gonna
listen to second nature from Russia's
album hold your fire and ice' if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
and minimus